now no sooner did justice breyer
announce his retirement then democrats
would swoop in to give him the bums rush
we need to do it quickly as quickly as
possible swiftly
expeditiously
we want to move quickly we want to get
this done as soon as possible our
judiciary committee will operate
expeditiously
they were trying to come up with every
synonym for the word quickly
well i bet they want it fast the stories
came flying in this morning right on cue
that the democrats expect a muted debate
over biden's nominee well as usual they
want to limit debate and preemptively
smear the opposition
they must like royalty because they want
a quickie coronation
but even susan collins isn't buying this
there is no need for any rush
we can take our time
have hearings go through the process so
why the hurry
i'll tell you why because this is what
the left's dark money trolls want
from the get-go the push to get justice
breyer to retire has been spearheaded by
a shady network of well-heeled dark
money groups that are working to subvert
not just to change or add to our
judiciary but to change our entire
system of government and frankly our
entire way of life
it's a left-wing cartel that we warned
you about over a year ago
meet the opaquely funded group called
demand justice which is really just a
front group for the 1630 fund
demand justice is led by former clinton
campaign spokesman brian fallon who
yesterday revealed how this group
bullied breyer off the court and how
they want the court to help validate a
far-left wish list of radical policies
from climate to gun control a year ago
we started publicly calling for
justice briar to step down what i hope
happens is that this opens people's
minds to what's possible in terms of
what the supreme court could be what it
could look like and we start to be a
little bit bolder and more imaginative
in reaction to rulings that are going to
come down in june on issues from
abortion to gun safety to the ability to
regulate greenhouse gases and that's
going to be
uh an occasion for democrats to see the
need to support expansion of the court
all that gun safety breaking out in
chicago these days now remember they're
not even trying to pretend
that this nomination involves complex
questions about statutory interpretation
constitutional philosophy or an analysis
there's only one thing that matters to
these vulture activists circling breyer
still warm on the side on his spot on
the bench
using the court to do what congress
doesn't have the votes to enact that's
what they want
the better name for the group demand
justice would be demand revolution
and these constitutional assassins don't
come cheap
a few years ago the washington free
beacon reported that george soros's open
society policy center marked that it had
sent 2.5 million to demand justice for
general support that was between april
1st and june 30th 2018 sources groups
sent 87 000 more between october 1st and
december 31st to support what they call
advocacy on judicial nominations
now the money's all fungible but some of
that money helped fund the highly
coordinated and vile attacks on justice
brett kavanaugh's confirmation
they were the ones waving those glossy
stop kavanaugh signs trying to derail
the confirmation hearings
now this same unsavory lot
intends to pick breyer's replacement
they don't deny that they shame briar
into retiring in fact they're proud of
it even featuring this headline on their
website
and demand justice ain't fringe my
friends they have friends and former
employees in very high places including
the white house
biden press secretary jen saki and paige
herwig who's biden's point person on
judicial nominations
both worked for the dark money group and
today saki was desperate to pre-span any
criticisms of biden's selection
if anyone is saying they plan to
characterize whoever he nominates after
throw consideration with both parties as
radical before they know literally
anything about who she is
they just obliterated their own
credibility
oh really and so long as she mentioned
no credibility it's not hard to imagine
who biden's going to choose as his
nominee demand justice has been pushing
cantanji brown jackson for a long time
they even posted this promotional video
last march
miss jackson
brings the entire package in one
candidate i'm fairly certain that if you
traced my family back past my
grandparents you would find that my
ancestors were slaves on both sides i
said
justice demands this result but she's
just getting warmed up
the good news is that it looks like
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
doesn't intend to let this nomination
pass without a real fight
mcconnell warned biden today that he
must not outsource this important
decision to the radical left
fat chance mitch biden's team needs 50
votes in the senate
and a lot of those votes would have to
come from senators who've spent their
whole careers trying to distance
themselves from the hard left
so it's up to you voters in the states
that elected these so-called moderate
democrats to exert as much political
pressure on them as possible
urging them to reject biden's soon to be
announced radical pick
i have a question tonight
do west virginians who voted for trump
by a roughly what 39 point margin
really support a supreme court justice
who believes in a racial caste system
now we understand that white supremacy
is not just nazis market marching in
charlottesville
white supremacy is the effort to
continue to hold on to power by any
means necessary
and to destroy
what you what you cannot control simply
because they don't want to share it with
black and brown people
of course they don't but joe manchin
seemed ready to get on board with the
radical express today
it's not too hard to get more liberal
than me uh so it would not bother me
having a person who was found in in
their disbursement of
justice and the rule of law
just because their personal beliefs
well okay
that means joe manchin
is willing to vote for a nominee
who would use her power to ban the main
industries of his home state
now remember the clean air acts language
can mean anything to a judicial activist
and the hard left wants west virginians
to go broke
for that matter they hate mansion but
apparently he's just willing to forgive
and forget
but you voters not in west virginia you
shouldn't forgive and forget
it's time to light up mansion's phone
in his office respectfully let him know
how you feel
but west virginians aren't the only ones
who need to call their senators
here's biden's current approval rating
in red and purple states with supposedly
moderate democrat senators
in nevada where catherine cortez-mastro
is up for election biden's approval is
just 46 percent
in georgia rafael warnock state biden
polls at a measly 34
new hampshire biden polls at 39 watch
out maggie hassan and in arizona binds
at 42 percent okay mark kelly think
carefully before you vote in lockstep
with the radicals
these democrats have a choice to make
are they going to do what the dark money
groups want
or are they going to listen to their own
voters i don't believe voters in any of
these states we forgot john tester in
montana want to turn the supreme court
into a rubber stamp for the msnbc crowd
now let's be clear
if you care about your second amendment
rights this nomination needs to be
stopped if you believe criminals should
be punished
this nomination needs to be stopped
if you believe that biden's team doesn't
actually have the power to shut down any
business that disagrees with dr fauci
this nomination oh yeah it needs to be
stopped
and if you believe that traditional
religious beliefs are protected by the
first amendment
this nomination needs to be stopped
we don't have to wait for the nomination
to get started
we know exactly what the left wants
a blank check to rewrite the
constitution and every u.s law that gets
in the way
regardless of the actual language
now it's time for senators across the
country
to hear from real americans who want to
keep their freedoms
this country belongs to us not to
biden's donors
and it should stay that way
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else